it's always great to return to Stanford
makes you wonder what makes me wonder
why I ever left seems like a pair
over here so I'll briefly introduce my
project interaction protocol which is
meant to facilitate IOT data
transactions so this is a slide that you
know I put together to read demonstrate
so the impetus you know for developing
this so what is it what problems are we
trying to solve in IOT that that
requires a solution like blocking right
so the idea behind it is that the vast
majority of IOT investments right even
as recent as 2015 have been investments
into hardware and infrastructure right
so the actual sensors and the sort of
storage and connectivity things like
that right well when you look at the
actual application there which is the
sort of green part of it right where the
data and analytics and actually people
creating value out of the data that's
collected by IOT devices that is a very
very small portion of the entire
investment and then based on a lot of
the projections from consulting firms
and english' groups you know five years
later even by 2020
you know once again the vast majority of
growth is still going to be occurring
inside infrastructure investments right
so the problem really with this picture
the key problem with this picture is
that unless this green part becomes the
majority or a huge portion of the
overall investment when we're not going
to see an explosive growth or adoption
of IOT technologies right because the
whole point of IOT is that or the whole
point of any technologies that you get
to see your return on your investment is
you cannot develop viable applications
analytics that actually drive growth
actually drive revenues and drive
profitability you're just never ever
going to get why why strat adoption
right so what are some of the key
obstacles I think you know people think
about when they think about so why
aren't people you know adopting IOT or
why aren't people sharing data more
widely with IOT right so the key problem
like I said before is that you know you
can't you can't really really get the
value out of IOT devices until you start
sharing and trading that data on a very
very wide basis so I saw a lot of people
you have access to that data
in order to develop by applications so I
think the good example I keep giving
people is short what is the most
successful IOT device you know sort of
in recent memory right it's actually the
smartphone the iPhone that is the most
successful IOT device and when Apple
created iPhone they made a very
interesting design choice or a business
decision is that they said that we're
going to open up this IOT device
hardware functionalities as well as its
data in the form of the app store so
that everybody around the world can
develop applications on top of it right
so there's a critical realization that
by sharing the data by sharing the
functionalities of IOT devices you can
actually create more value not less but
this is not the way that most people
think right this is not the way that
most people who have IOT devices or have
IOT data or could have IOT devices and
data think about it right so what were
some of the what are some of the
constraints and obstacles that that sort
of bar people from sharing their IOT
data right so first of all there's a lot
of there's a lot of concerns around data
security you know network constraints
you know a lot of things that sort of
deal with the fact that it might really
the owner of this data am i going is my
data going to be exposed to the wider
world are my competitors going to get
visibility into my business operations
right so when watching you have a
cryptographically secure network right
where devices are not very easy
compromise where the data are
cryptographic is secured and ownership
is guaranteed through signatures right
so that I think goes a long way to
address the problem with you know with
data security as well as privacy
concerns right you're also going to the
problem of people thinking about costs
right lack of use cases in the high cost
so a lot of the costs are going to IOT
is not just the costs of the hardware
but also the cost of storage the costs
of analytics right so a lot of these
costs are sort of building a lot of them
are fixed it's very very difficult to
get out of long-term contracts with a
lot of vendors so what's really good
about blocking is that it's very good at
rationalizing resources it's not only
it's a very good at franchising
resources is also very good at making
use of underutilized resources right so
if your are on a blocking system you can
basically rent storage or rent process
power mostly in the form of our
contracts and also in a lot of other
sort of botching projects such as Gollum
you are actually able to basically pay
for exactly the tiny amount of storage
and processing power and resources that
you use right there's no long-term
contracts inside there's really nothing
that prevents you from from using or
paying for exactly what you need right
there's a there there's always there's
always the risk of people thinking that
they might become overly dependent upon
an individual vendor or a third party
when they start sharing the data and
I'll start outsourcing the data
analytics to third parties right well we
have a decentralized ecosystem with with
blockchain technology so that you're
never really dealing with a single
entity or you're dealing with a very
very wide network of different people so
at any given time you don't really have
to be worried about that you're becoming
dependent on a third party right and
then I think probably the most the most
problematic problem and obstacle in IOT
is the idea that you don't have valuable
business cases right how do I make money
off of this IOT device how do I make
money off the data that I create now one
of the things I say is that while
blotching is not going to magic invent
business models for you that's nothing
in the world magic invents business
models for you but I think what blocking
is very very good at is that it's very
very good at sourcing a lot of open
innovation from the open source
community right it's very very good at
getting people to collaborate on a
specific task from from Inglot in a very
distributed manner right so one of the
things that in just using the iPhone we
example is that you know if you don't
open things up if we don't start sharing
things if you don't start trading things
then you'll never be able to figure out
the maximum value of the assets that you
have in the form of IOT data right so
it's sort of a chicken and egg problem
creates a vicious cycle is that the more
you sort of hoard your data the more you
hold your devices the less uses that you
yourself are going to think of because
as an individual company you're not
going to have the most brilliant people
are concentrated within your company to
figure out all every single possible use
case right so that's sort of a vicious
cycle and I think blotching by breaking
down all the barriers
sharing the data can actually help
propel people to share more data in in
that sense in your help create more
business cases in there and use cases so
on a sort of a low level I think
blotting is very interesting that
enables devices to become sort of it
becomes a very different entity right so
the way that I think about sort of the
interplay between AI and blockchain as
related to a specific IOT device is that
you know AI helps the device to
understand what it needs to do right the
device knows what it needs to do next
blockchain enables the device to do the
things that it needs to do so blocking
gives devices unique identities in the
form of you know a private public key a
with those keys because they can start
signing things it gives the device this
concept of ownership right devices can
now own things right now we own devices
devices don't don't know any anything
else right now taking own things right
and also the third thing is that because
they can own things they can also start
transacting with other devices or other
entities on the network those other
entities could be software hardware they
could be people they could be other
devices whatever right so if you're for
example or I say you're a weather sensor
right in the middle a weather station
right so normally what will happen is
that you know me I pray you know I
bought the weather center some weather
station owns the weather sensor so they
you know they upload the data to their
central server and then they sit there
and figure out we're not going to do
with this data right so that's sort of
how things work right now but in the
future if devices become sufficient
intelligent and the network becomes
sufficiently mature that device sitting
there has its own ideas about what it
can do with that data
alright for example you can say that hey
you know actually I know that there are
you know you know data markets out there
that I can actually sell my data so I'm
going to hook myself onto that data
market and say here's the data I have
I'm gonna be able to sell it and maybe
also at the same time I know that hey
you know there are algorithms out there
that could actually improve the
sensitivity or the analytics
which I can use to process data and I
can just by sort of that the algorithm
or actually borrow the processing power
of that algorithm or rent it so it's
actually able to make independent
decisions without human intervention
right so like I said AI makes the device
know what it needs to do
watching allows the device to do the
things that initially right okay so
we're talking about a lot of very
abstract concepts right let's talk about
applications right and this is sort of a
lot of is sort of bang of IOT is that
successful business models are
incredibly rare to find so several here
to give you I'll talk about the first
few examples the first one is the idea
of cars so cars have a lot of data that
is that is generating so we're currently
working with this company our car block
and what car bhaktas is that they
actually have over a million vehicles in
North America installed with their smart
devices are uploading a ton of data
about the cars lemon tree who's gonna
buy that data well insurance companies
want to buy that data to better assess
the risk of driver behavior based on
driver behavior you know car repair
chains won't you buy that data to to be
able to acquire customers already and
also to better set to better optimize
their supply chain in terms of parts and
technician allocations for their
different branches so you get less less
sort of rejection rate you know when the
customers walking so you know this is
this is a this is a this is an area
where you have a large data set right so
cars generate a lot of data right so in
a traditional model if a small subset of
that data is useful for some reason then
will accompany with you is that they
would just take that small data set out
and sell it to the person who wants it
and that's it that would be sure the end
of how these things work now what we
actually want to do and actually what
Carbaugh quants to do is hey why don't
we leverage the one or two business
valuable business models right actually
make make it so it's worth it that
consumers actually purchase these
devices worth it for the manufacturers
to make this to these devices the entire
value chain just works out
why don't we leverage those small
business models that are relevant to a
subset of the
brought dataset and we just use that you
should get the entire dataset expose the
entire dataset for training right so
that's what this is all about is that we
really try to democratize all the data
that has been formerly locked into sort
of databases and devices that had not
been sort of seen the light of day right
so who knows what that data could be
used for so that's really the beauty of
a lot of these applications the second
one we talked about is it's cropped
intelligence so one of the one of the
largest clients that I've worked with
when I was a previously a strategy
consultant this company called ingenta
so we actually helped them set their
global digital strategy as foster China
strategy and one of the things that you
know we sort of learned while we're
working with them is that you know as at
least in a Chinese market people have
increasingly started using drones to
deploy crop protection products so they
use drones to spray pesticides because
the rising for awareness of safety as
well as the rising cost of human labor
drone delivery actually starts to make a
lot of sense so there are all these
drone operators all across China with
fleets of drones that would just move
from region to region right during
during spraying seasons to spray
pesticides on the cross these drones
could be collecting a lot of data they
could be collecting tons of data for
example if you just put a camera on
those drones they can take the photos to
the crops that they're spraying over
with those photos where you can tell us
you can help the type of crop you can
tell the crop growth stage you can tell
what type of pests are in the crop
insects weeds
fungi and bacteria infections okay so
that data set is non-existent right now
nobody has that data set because it's
never been collected but here we have
hundreds of thousands of drones flying
around not collecting that data which
they very well could be right so walk
who needs that data who who's willing to
pay for that data well agriscience
companies like Syngenta likethey're
monsanto dial dupont they would love to
pay for that data right so it gives them
market intelligence who's printing what
we're it gives them understanding of
diseases how spreading so they can model
disease spreading behavior so they can
better allocate their sales and
marketing spend as well as coordinate
their supply chain manager
all right farmers will definitely let
you have this date right for example if
I'm a watermelon farmer you know and I
want to know hey should I be planting
watermelons in the next season
this is something I never realized until
I got into agriculture was that it's a
huge gamble
agriculture is a huge gamble every
season you're gambling on what you
should be planting right so what usually
happens in China and I'm sure probably
harvesting a lot of developing countries
is that no one knows what you plant so
they'll say well you know mr. Wallen
last year he made a ton of money doing
watermelon so we're all gonna do
watermelons this year right so you get
oversupply and watermelons rotting the
field and a lot of Mom's horrible no
it's a little kind of watermelons that's
time tomatoes next year everyone plant
tomato next year and everyone gets
screwed right so it's really this
mentality that really causes this boom
and bust sort of cycle in agriculture
it's very very very risky for the
farmers right it's actually very bad for
everybody involved because the farmers
lose a lot of money the government has
to come in and clean it up or has a riot
on his hands all kinds of bad things so
the farmers would love to know who's
planting what right if they know that
you know the ten surrounding villages
are all planting one thing maybe I
shouldn't be planting that right maybe I
should planning something else they were
allowed to know about pests right so if
there's a throw back you know locusts
are coming my way
you know 100 kilometers away I should be
stocking up on pesticides right you
prevent the fact that you know their
local color so that dataset is also
non-existent and farmers will loved you
you know half that data and I'm sure
they're not going to pay for it because
these crop protection companies are
choosing to buy that data and give it to
the farmers as value have the services
to promote their own products right so
this is another instance where we see
that there there could be very very
valuable business models for data that
goes uncollected
right and that data could also be shared
you know on you know on your data market
for IOT de tomar right okay so before I
talk about this I mean I guess I guess
I'll talk about sort of why is it that
we thought it was necessary to create a
new protocol right so why reinvent the
wheel right why can't we just use what's
out there today right so this is backing
sort of 2017 when we're starting
investigate
you know why you know how how could we
use barching given that it has such so
many complementary properties with IOT
that it could be used to really advance
the field can we actually use some of
the existing technologies that we've
seen right so if you looked at some of
the general purpose platform such as
Hysterium you know we all know that a
theorem has a lot of you know sort of
throughput k throughput and scalability
issues right you know single like you
know crypto kiddie out can clog up the
entire network so that wasn't really
viable that we think if you start
cooking up buildings of IOT devices to
this platform it's gonna it's gonna
choke like there's no tomorrow right so
that's really not gonna work out then we
look at other technologies something
like Yoda right which properties are
designed specifically for IOT devices
and and we found out that from Yoda's
consensus algorithm has some pretty
fundamental flaws with it it's very
easily spammed actually the shorter the
random walk way that it actually
validates these these transactions
create huge problems like so your
transaction could be verified in seconds
or weeks depends on how lucky you are
right and also if you're unlucky and
your transaction accidentally landed on
a double spend well two weeks later your
transaction that you thought was you
know sort of validated it could be
overturned right because you know the
sort of consensus algorithm does not
have a full view of the entire network
I'm sure they're working hard to fix it
just not really sure when that's going
to actually going to happen so at the
time when we started looking at a lot of
the existing solutions we found out that
he actually nothing really simple when
you actually need it okay so I'm not
going to talk about the first one
because it's probably less relevant but
I'm gonna talk about the next three so
when you're talking about IT devices
you're always talking about a device
that's very limited computational and
storage capabilities so we all know that
you're running phone node on a network
like Bitcoin or etherium it requires a
ton of computation power and a ton of
storage space like not even close right
now your laptop can't even do it and if
you're talking about your phone or even
like an IOT gateway just forget about
that's not gonna work so normally what
will happen is that conventional sort of
like no implementations basically said
that
usually have to trust a phone no
blinding because you can you can do
anything right so we found that okay so
maybe for certain use cases that's
interesting but you know if we actually
really want to enable device autonomy
that they can actually become an
independent entity and participant on a
network it has to be you know pretty
trust us it doesn't really need to trust
anybody else so one of the things that
we actually set out to do is create a
set of designs to enable light notes so
the IOT devices and IOT gateways can
actually be able to tell over the
network by itself what's true and what's
not using the exact same consensus
algorithm that the rest of the network
uses okay the net the next one is we
called concurrent smart contract system
right so you know when you talk about
IOT devices we talked about devices
trading most the time when they're
trading they're not trading coins right
it's not like devices are you know I'm
gonna give you a coin give me a coin
most of the time they're trading
information they're trading data right
so that's most of time what they're
doing and data are trading fundamentally
requires a smart contracts if nothing
else just to make sure there's no
counterparty risk right so once again
smart contract is gonna be the primary
bottleneck for existing blocking systems
right so when we actually develop is
that we have developed with concurrent
smart contract system that enables two
things so on the single individual node
a node is able to process hundreds of
contract calls simultaneously in
parallel right unlike for example an
cerium they do it you know in sequence
right and then across across the network
right across the network what we're
doing is that we're making sure that the
first time anybody processes any given
contract call there's only one note
that's processing it that means there's
no waste at work right so on something
that you cerium you know you have 10,000
miners you know 9999 of them just wasted
their work every single round right
because only one block when it's out
alright so on this on our on our network
that doesn't happen right everybody's
work is as valuable
no one's worth is wasted and and yeah in
order is is well is well defined
and the third thing that we are that we
are that we are doing is what's called
encrypted data market so I think this is
gonna be the first deal that we actually
create on top of the fracture protocol
because we think that it's going to be
very very interesting and primary use
case of the Transfer Protocol is to
allow devices to sell their data to
other entities who want to purchase the
data right so it's a combination of
encryption algorithms that are mature
algorithms that allow the devices to
encrypt the data that they upload into
or into anywhere since it's encrypted
it allows encrypted search enables
transactions of historical data you're
also able subscriptions to data streams
right so everything is encrypted so I
think this is what this gives the device
that created a data perfect control over
who gets to see that data and it makes
it agnostic on where it actually stores
the data right and this is another sort
of very key I think application for for
for adoption in in terms of IOT data
trade I won't go into a lot of details
with the technology yeah so a lot of
people actually talk about you know this
is actually this is actually interesting
hopping is that a lot of people actually
asks or how how do you make money right
so how how does tracks to make money
right this what's your business model
and what's very interesting is that in
sort of blocking ecosystems the team
actually creates a protocol has no
business model right so we don't charge
money we don't have any revenue we're
not really allowed to have any sales so
we can't charge anyone any money so our
job as the founding team of Trachta is
to drive the adoption of the protocol
right and what's in it for me
are watching it for us because we hold a
certain amount of tokens that are that
are helped by the team so we are heavily
assented to make sure that there's wide
adoption of our protocol so that our
tokens rising values so this is basing
you think of it as sort of the ecosystem
is a country and sort of tokens are
service currency and I want to increase
GDP of this country in order to increase
the value for my career
right so I'm not really here to charge
people money I'm here to get people to
use it as much as possible the more they
use it they're more valuable my holdings
are right so this actually makes it very
very easy for us to work with people
because when people hear that you you're
here to you know do free work with me
you know they're very happy right it's
very happy they do free work that's
great right so you know we're able to
work with a large number of different
players across the entire value chain
and we're really here to develop
ecosystem players that can dip they
themselves can develop you know very
viable and traditional business models
on top of our protocol right so one of
the things that we're heavily looking at
are players who are interested in
creating data markets right so so like
for example the car box is an example
there's another company that we are
opening for a negotiation with it's
actually in agriculture it's a it's an
apple it's an Apple company they didn't
make or they grow apples and they
process outpost and they sell apples
right so they are you know they're based
in western China and they're also very
interested in leveraging blocking
technology to really start sharing and
trading agricultural data so that they
can start to create standardized
solutions standardized planting
solutions right for agriculture that's
that's a whole other interesting topic
that we can talk about later if you're
interested it allows the securitization
of farmland income so we're looking for
companies specifically with the
resources the expertise and the vision
to create useful decentralized data
markets so that can they can help to
start democratizing their data and they
themselves become sort of a portal right
where other people find data within a
specific vertical right so just like car
Bach I mean in a lot of cases right a
lot of these companies what they can do
is that they can actually go with the
traditional business model right which
they can say I'm gonna hoard all this
data and I'm gonna play the information
asymmetry game and I'm just gonna make
tons of money off of other people's data
right I mean that's what almost every
single internet company does today right
so it actually does take a certain
amount of vision and and guts to
actually say that I'm going to throw
away this tried-and-true pitts model
that gives me very high
Asians because I believe that this D
centrifuge is coming in rather than
being disrupted by others I'm just going
to proactively disrupt myself before
someone's it else disruption right so
it's actually pretty pretty interesting
yeah so this is none during this is sort
of a more in-depth example of how the
car blocking ecosystem will work so so
yeah so you have a so you have the
hardware maker the device makers and on
that they making smart devices that go
into cars that you know that in the car
owners actually purchase and install and
run under car block app and in the car
block they run the data market which
then sells data to people like insurance
companies and and and car repair shops
and tracks that in the back end they
will provide you know services to embed
the the protocol onto their hardware you
know they can they can provide free
technical support you create apps for
four four four car block it can also
help car block build these data markets
and actually drive volume aren't you
there on to the Dare market okay so all
these services are free right you have
to pay your cost yes that's why we need
to raise money yeah okay but this this
is generally people raise money up front
because all have revenue later
yeah so this is very interesting so once
again I actually actually gave a talk at
um Amity I can just a ministry of
economic and trade and industry in Japan
yeah so I was I was yeah they they asked
me this question as well which in which
case I said that look I mean I think
well I wrote this whole other article
about my vision for decentralized future
so my philosophy is that large companies
in general well first of all companies
are getting larger and larger right
because we need to you know sort of
increasingly coordinate more as
technology becomes more and more complex
having a viable business requires a
larger larger amounts of coordination of
resources right so for example before
the Industrial Revolution that you have
a 20-person company like that's a huge
company 20 people right so you know you
know you have industrial whooshing have
an information revolution you have all
these tech a lot
Vance's actually you know mandate that
you start coordinating a lot of
resources and our creates huge companies
along with huge companies you have
multi-layer management you have me
running to like ten top layers of
management you have huge bureaucracy set
on the side to coordinate the sort of
information flow in the resource flow
right and people make poor decisions
right because every single company is a
planned economy it's actually very
interesting things and we're all taught
that market economies are very efficient
but every single company is a planning
company and increasingly we're living in
a world where it were dominated by huge
multinational corporations who are plan
economies and when they deal with each
other they deal with each other to
create planned economies right so this
is this is this is this is a trend that
has not really been reversed
you know since time immemorial a
company's get bigger and bigger bigger
organizations become bigger and bigger
and bigger they become very inefficient
they stand out innovation and they are
disrupted by smaller companies right I
actually spent a good part of my
consulting career teaching large
companies how do you behave more like
small startups right it's it's not easy
right it's not easy so really the idea
is how blocking is actually an
interesting way for you to actually
start to Delayer these organizations and
actually start breaking down large
corporations and economic entities into
smaller entities right now in order to
create these type of inko systems right
companies and markets an ecosystem don't
just spring out of nowhere from the from
you know from day one so the idea of a
this type of like like for example like
tracks are right as a as a as the
project team or as a company or whatever
you want to call it it's it's an
interesting setup because it's an
organization that set up in the
beginning to be highly centralized to
drive adoption and to improve the
ecosystem but as time goes on the more
successful they become the more
unnecessary they make themselves and in
fact as time goes on they're actually
not really able to incur any kind of
change within the ecosystem because if
as more and more people adopt a protocol
and doctor ecosystem they're their voice
be
comes diminish over time and then after
a while they just become asleep right so
it's very very interesting isn't it sort
of like you know you start with the
monarchy that's guaranteed to evolve
into a democracy by design right because
you just never use not gonna you know
you're not going to be able to hold on
to that power over time so this is this
is why you know you know if you raise
how much money you raise you know the
team doesn't need revenue because the
team should disappear out four or five
to ten years if we do your job right the
team should just disappear and it
shouldn't exist because if it exists
forever you know that's like you know
it's a monarchy forever right it's like
the you know Lenin set the transitional
government right we're gonna have to the
dictatorship of the proletariat that
never goes away well this goes away by
design all right so it's very
interesting that was a very long-winded
answer to your question because this is
kind of anti the classic startup
mentality right yeah we're gonna start
our company we're gonna grow it
eventually we will exit in one big you
know exchange that's either being bought
by some bigger company and going public
and becoming in a huge crop land economy
yeah yeah a huge economy and I think I
think Peter Theo said that there's no
reason to create a start-up unless you
expect you to become monopoly right yeah
so I mean all you see I mean this is
another thing that I sort of talked
about which is that you know in business
being a strategy consultant we always
talk about competitive advantages how do
you build up competitive advantages so
that others cannot enter into your
market right pitch that you give to
investors right I mean we ask that many
questions at this point I guess so yeah
I mean no I tell I mean anyone who's
willing for this and it's this is what I
just want to tell them right so and if
you and we also talked about varying
busy also talk about sustainable
competitive Vantage's which are very
rare
but if you're able to achieve it then
that creates a natural monopoly right
and you just you just have something
that builds on top of each other over
time that you become so powerful then
you start to corner the market right so
that is very very very good for
shareholders that accompany right and
it's very natural for that company as an
economic entity to maximize his own
profits and maximize any advantages its
able to build right but it's not very
great for society as a whole because
it's inefficient right so large
companies as they gain more power as
they gain more advantages they start to
behave I would say very poor teen
interns that are behaved very
inefficiently they start playing games
with information asymmetry they start
having rent-seeking behaviors right so
you have all sorts of bad behaviors
which large corporations that have truly
sustainable competitive advantages that
are actually very bad for society as a
whole right so what you really want to
do and this is not really possible but
you may might might not be perfectly
possible but my idea is that you want to
introduce as much perfect competition as
you can and remove sources of
competitive advantage and make
everything of equal playing field
right so my sort of perfect future is
that every single industry work like you
know sort of high-frequency trading
right where any sort of advantage can
appear and quickly disappear in
microseconds as soon as develop a viable
trading strategy you start trading the
market and then you know other
algorithms start catching up and you'll
kill your arbitrage opportunity and
there is no there is no economic
opportunity cost right so that's that's
sort of a more idealized with okay
here's Tariq so then I'm at the bottom
level yeah right at the the sort of
platform level for this is the data that
you're dealing with really essentially
does it divide itself up into tokens are
we talking about something where
individuals could have an IC o---- and
all buy a bunch of tokens living out all
right so so tokens are I mean people
people keep questioning so why do you
need a token right why is that necessary
so I think from me from the functional
perspective tokens are used to fuel the
sort of the operations in the network so
for example if someone performs an
action for you like process one contract
then you need to get paid and they get
paid in your token so that's more like
at the level of the the car block then
because I know they talk about
tokens yeah there's a couple types of
tokens right so yeah there are a couple
types of tokens yeah so so what
so you made me want to talk about the
difference between coins and tokens
right coins are usually the native
currency that's generated on the
blockchain right tokens as people
usually talk to them and 99% of all icos
are are such such forms of tokens is
that there's smart contracts actually
created on top of an existing platform
for most of having seat area so they by
themselves don't have a lot of
functionality other than the fact that
they're a representation of value you
know for the ecosystem which i think is
actually actually Trump's sort of the
utility functionality but a decision
you've got a piece of data
mm-hm you know if you're if you're
dividing up data to like take this data
from yeah some weather station or from
you know crop information or whatever
yeah are people really buying the pieces
of data yeah people are purchasing data
yeah who are purchasing data with the
tokens right yeah right um yeah okay so
does that mean that your company would
kind of be at a level to enable those
kind of token purchases
well we or is that higher level in the
stack okay so the tokens okay if the
coins for toxsa are they are their pre
minted and they're distributed according
to a certain distribution schedule right
some of is some of those investors some
of it goes to your free giveaway some of
those are investment items yeah but
those things are used on the they're
used on the platform and an ecosystem it
use on the yes it's like yeah they're
used on the ecosystem as as a form of
payment and they're also a
representation of value for the
ecosystem so so a lot of people will ask
for why do you need a separate token or
why need a separate call you mean there
are obvious technological reasons in
that if you create something like
there's a completely new protocol
they're not going to be compatible with
any other existing tokens anyway you
could create atomic swap protocols to
swap it with other Copeland's that's
fine but at the end of the day because
your Ledger's fundamentally different
than the other Ledger's you need your
own token but I think more important
realize that specific token is or the
coin is a representation of value for
the ecosystem so you can think of it
it's sort of like I mean it is the
currency right is the currency it's like
a US dollar right yeah I mean there's
probably not a whole lot of point talk
about this but you know there are a lot
of IOT projects out there I'm probably
missing a lot UI reasons that are all
those blocked using blockchain yes
I'll reason boxing in one form or
another yeah okay
and her axis is distinctive in what way
so Trust is distinctive in the fact that
while in the in the mostly I think in
the light no implementations right
because I think were the were probably
the only project that I know of that
actually puts a lot of time into
designing light notes to allow devices
to become trusts as participants on
network and and we also are the only
world owning project that has concurrent
smart contracts okay and you know
encrypted data markets I think there are
certain people that might be creating it
there so I think there's a project in
the Bay Area called new cipher that's
actually creating all these encrypted
data markets so you know there are a few
players in that in that in that field as
well yeah so I think that's probably a
good introduction ok good start
we've got there a lot of things that I
want to ask you about and talk to you
about first of all I want to ask did
being in China have anything to do with
you coming up with the idea for Florida
blockchain protocol company yeah because
I think that's that's an interesting
question so now I don't know if I could
have come up with a had I not been in
China but I can I can start to talk
about how I came up with this IOT plus
blocking idea right so my first startup
in China was a hardware startup that
makes mesh networks that was back in
2009 2010 which is I think in retrospect
might have been way too early for for
IOT but it was it was interesting
because it got me chose sort of pre deep
into the IOT field and start
understanding further them
nations and advantages of IOT devices
both from a technology perspective I
sauce from a commercial perspective in
terms of blockchain I think I was very
interesting because China has China has
been always sort of been pretty early in
the cryptocurrency field I think for the
longest time it was the largest sort of
mining base of operation for Bitcoin
until the governments were abandoned and
everyone started moving out
it's probably the largest trading volume
in the world and Bob I think Bobby's
BTCC was for probably half a year or
nine months the largest exchange in the
world
for Bitcoin so it's pretty impressive
and and yeah and it was also the region
where I think for for a long time the
vast majority investments into blocking
projects came from actually if you talk
to a lot of the early projects here in
even anywhere in the world right he
Silicon Valley or whatever they're all
very cognizant about who gave them their
money right the Chinese people gave him
their money so so I think China has been
a very interesting hotbed for
cryptocurrency and and I was um I first
got introduced who bought a two-bit
corner thinking 2013 when Bobby told me
about Bitcoin they're just in called
Bitcoin unfortunately I didn't buy any
or I thought very little that was
unfortunate because back then I was very
very I think was like 200 USD per coin
so could have made a lot of money and
and I think after he told me about it
and the Central Bank of China declared
that it's not a currency and banned all
you know financial institutions from
working with crypto exchanges so you
start seeing actually this steady
decline starting you know beginning of
2014 and Bitcoin prices you start
dropping like crazy you know the drop
for the rest of the year into 2015 so
that's sort of like diminish my from
increasing in Bitcoin and then towards
the end of 2015
another Stanford alum Alex Leo who's the
founder of my coin in Taiwan and he told
me hey there's a thing called boxing
right it's actually the technology that
that's powering Bitcoin so you should
looking to so I went to a hackathon in
Shanghai that was actually backed by
that was actually founded by them or
coordinated by the LOI and this other
company called wine shell which is a
huge conglomerate it's actually a
largest private enterprise in China and
the earliest institutional investor into
blocking in the world right so it's very
interesting and you know at that at that
meeting you know I met like you know I
guess today there would be you know
considered luminaries in the feeling I
met in vitalik at the time he was just a
Russian kidding but Halleck right so and
met a lot of people there who who
actually went on to bill if any
successful companies in with with boxing
technology so at that time I think it
was sort of spent a lot of time thinking
about it and and watching at the time I
think vast majority of applications
people were talking about were private
Kings private chains and consortium
chains right so your brother consortium
chain between banking and insurance and
all these financial institutions right
so very interesting you know not not
that exciting not that exciting right so
it seems like watching was just another
piece of like ERP software or some kind
that you do and you know if you get into
a become IT consultant you know great
you know that's doesn't seem that
disruptive or world-changing right and
so in 2017 I had another chance to
actually look at IOT you know IOT of
devices because Chris Christie probably
know Christa he another classmate of
mine we we were looking at you know sort
of investment projects between Japan and
China and one of the companies were
looking at was this Japanese IOT company
so we started looking at the IOT company
that was my other chance to sort of get
back into I out here so now let's look
at it again and found that you know the
field hasn't really progressed as much
as I thought it would so we started
looking into blockchain and then
coincidentally another another Cosmin
under Stanford cos we in the mines name
was Jimbo Jimbo Wong so he is at the
time I think he was head of trading for
ETS for Deutsche Bank so he very
abruptly quit his job and say I'm
joining his blocking startup so I don't
like what why was he at the time was he
he was in Hong Kong okay she was in Hong
Kong and and then so I asked him more
about you know what's going on
so apparently his high school classmates
whom I happen to actually not in
retrospect she played poker with them
and so his high school classmates
actually or operating largest ICO
platform in China car ICO H so at the
time they they took up about a third of
China's overall ICO fundraising
activities and China was taking up I
think over a third of global CEO uh
fundraising right so so they were huge
they were huge and and so so he was
gonna join them and then they were going
to in the process of creating a
decentralized exchange right so so it's
all very exciting and then and then you
know the government shot everything down
so so then so then so then they become
very worried you know what what are we
going to do and then Chris and I started
thinking about you know our resources in
Japan and you know Japan at the time
this is you know you know at the time it
was September right of 2017 and until
now actually it you know crypto changes
they're still legal in Japan so we
actually introduced them to partners who
had or in the process of applying for
our crypto exchange licenses so they can
create partnerships and create legal
entities right so I think having a
government crackdown in China really
really really I think chased a lot a lot
of interesting changes all our resources
and technology out of China so very very
unfortunate that I think China this is
actually one area where China actually
has two rubber leg up on the rest of the
world because there's so much activity
there and I think was very well poised
to actually take advantage of this new
technology right but in the end you know
most people forgot out and it was
through all these sort of series of
events right this sort of happened
starting from 2013 all the way till you
know through 2017 I think that China
being me being China was was very
interesting because blockchain was
something that was happening it was
really a hotbed of activity right what
boshy in China so had happened somewhere
else maybe not as much because as far as
I understand it well
lashing has always right now you Vanessa
stands today is sort of a fringe kind of
a technology right so respectable people
don't talk about blockchain right that's
that's for you know the scammers so so I
think in China it it has this sort of
you know it was it was very very big it
was very very big in China so had I live
somewhere else maybe I would not have
been exposed to so much of this stuff
and because of my personal connections
in in my you know my sort of social
circles that I was able to actually hear
about a lot of these things I think
probably earlier than other people would
have so that's you know yeah I think the
in China does have some how much what
kind of ongoing technology development
is required for connect so what kind of
R&D work are you gonna have to do from
this point yeah so we are actually so we
need to create the protocol we're
referencing our protocol on the on top
of another project called nano so now
though I think was released towards the
in the last year and introduces very
innovative block lattice topology which
which i think is very very interesting
it's also specifically interesting for
light notes because it has a naturally
sharded you know ledger write per
account and you know in our case also
for smart contract but anyway so I think
for us we need to borrow that concept
and actually build a smart contract on
the system on top of it alright so
that's that's sort of rnt work that we
need to do it's it's actually quite a
bit of work I mean what about the talent
where yeah how it really distributed all
over the world yeah the talent is so the
talent is interesting that you can't go
out and just hire a blocking expert
right so if someone tells you they're a
blocking expert they're either a
billionaire or they're trying to scam
you that's sort of how this how this
works right so so what you're really
looking at or what I'm really looking at
right so I think I first kicked out this
project towards the end of last year and
very quickly I started realizing is that
it was very very difficult to convince a
lot of my classmates and friends who are
not really interesting blocking or have
heard a lot about it to sort of cross
over right into the dark side of
blushing
so what ended up happening was that the
most effective way to recruit people is
a street talk up talk with people on
open-source communities right so you're
already your own discord you're a slack
you're talking to various people in
projects and you're very discretely
talking to them secret like you're
interesting practicing my project so and
then you make some posts you talk to a
lot of people you build up your your
personal reputation people think you're
you know kind of a legit guy and you
know be kind of cool to work with so so
that's one way another way is actually
through academia right so one of the
interesting I found is that one of our
not one of our primary advisor is
Professor Mars Haruki who is a a
professor at Brown University in a world
authority in distributed computing and
concurrency so I found him because I
started reading a lot of academic papers
right because as a set of very specific
problems that I need to solve and there
were since no one else and blockchain
was doing anything related to it so I
had to go back and read academic papers
and I found a lot of research you know
that Professor hurt he did that was
relevant to what I was wrong what I
wanted to do and it just so happened
that he's also very interested in
blocking as well so I just you know
konima him and got him on board so
heading through that connection I was
able to actually get a lot of people
from academic backgrounds to actually
collaborate with me on this project so
it's also very interesting because I
think when academics when they normally
when they work with businesses or or
commercial entities right it's always
sort of what's under IP lock and IP was
proprietary I can't publish on this or
that usually there are a lot of rules on
what you can and cannot publish so when
I first met professor Herlihy I was
talking to him so he asked me the same
question I said what can we publish and
I said yeah it's all open source like
there's no IP you can publish anything
and you say wow that's that's refreshing
right that's that's seem kind of nice
right so I said yeah it's perfect the
more papers you publish the better right
in fact later I'm willing to fund
academic research right because that
advances sort of the sort of state of
the technology so so yeah I mean
academia and then just talking to people
online finding people that's sort of
their sort of
Asura is really not geographically yeah
so that's I think this is probably one
of the well in recent memory I guess one
of the few sort of software innovations
that has not really sprung up in Silicon
Valley uh-huh
I think I think that's a fair statement
right now so I think that's a fair
statement a lot of teams after they
build up their technologies have come to
Silicon Valley because you know this is
liz's the face to come right obviously
and but I don't think a lot of
technologies actually grew out of
Silicon Valley and yeah so don't say
it's very global I'm still trying to
wrap my head around this kind of anti
startup description you've given of Thai
Rak so so how do you reward people for
the effort that they put into building
the contracts and this kind of stuff you
pay them right
you mean building the the system yeah
building the system you keep calling it
a project building the company yeah yeah
building a protocol right so yeah so
first of all they get pay since you know
living obviously if you're in live as
such in the Bay Area it's not cheap yeah
right the so second of all they get a
token allocations okay which you can
think of it's for like shall I start off
kind of like sessions all right so so
yeah so that's that's that's how do you
okay but that companies that the company
has to grow in a certain way in value
yes so that their token allocations will
be worth more yes exactly I know but
what's growing in value is not the
company what's growing in value is the
ecosystem okay yeah so the more people
participating the ecosystems are about
more valuable your token becomes okay
right so you can there's a website
called : market Capcom you know that
that sort of tells you about the market
capitalization of all these different
projects so that's how you can ascertain
well so how valuable some how long do
you think the life of this is before you
just say okay victory go home troops
five ten years and then basically
everybody find your next project that's
very hard to tell how long it would take
because so it's because were a protocol
project right we're I think it's my view
on blushing protocols is that right now
there are a lot of different protocols
but protocols as you know they ought the
date they are to behave right as we see
from history is that they will
inevitably in converge right so right
now there might be like 10 20 30
different protocols but later on there
should probably be one or two or three
right so they were all converged in the
fact that they're all open-source makes
it easy for them to converge because
then you will start borrowing features
and functionalities from each other and
then they would just convert right so
then when what this is the kind of thing
that I'm sort of surprised with nobody
like IDM is trying to push one but they
are developing in-house well I think you
have hyper nature which they're pushing
so so you know a big company with
billions of dollars of marketing budget
you know a worldwide organization why
aren't they running you out
Barney running me out yeah yeah that's
that's interesting
hmm I haven't found you yet this may be
a dangerous presentation yeah I don't
know I mean I mean I think I think I
think a lot of these larger corporations
increase solutions for private chains
right and I see so there's an re now out
there to create public change because
like I said a lot of the public chain of
occasions really threaten the existing
business models of corporations right
because it tends to break them down and
start to remove they're sort of some
very competitive advantages so large
companies really like private chains
right in fact I think there's a large
set of capital out there the specific
the only fund private projects because
it makes very simple economic sentences
that I do a project for you you pay me
write notes that's the end of that
that's for sure in the automobile world
you can almost guarantee that you've got
the Toyota ecosystem and then yeah you
know Ford ecosystem and how do we live
them with
any kind of community I mean that's
that's really what's for wrong I mean
not not I mean so in IOT I wonder the
other biggest problem is that every
single manufacturer wants to create our
own standard right you know my own
standard my standard is going to kill
the world and blah blah blah right so of
course then no one else thinks like you
obviously think their standards gonna
take over the world and so then you have
all these silos of different standards
and they try to very hard to make them
incompatible with one another because
that's how you defend your market your
market share right so that does not
create more value that creates less
value over time but but in your short
term if you're looking at quarterly
earnings you're not gonna know that's
not that's not how corporations are in
sentence yeah yeah okay that's all of
the Florida questions quit Scott this is
really fascinating is the Traxxas
blockchain as a public protocol
something that even a currency say out
of the Chinese government could help
provide the blockchain ledger structure
for and is it done primarily in Mandarin
astir AXA a mandarin speaking country
I'm interested in the large comparison
yeah it's the blockchain ledger so so
this is very interesting to answer your
question actually I you know maybe if
you asked me this last week I wouldn't
been able to give me an answer but so um
we we didn't do any marketing right so
we don't really know who knows about us
and who doesn't know about this and last
Tuesday I remember these things because
they are very very very interesting I
updated my left side because you know
for a longest time I had a single page
website it didn't say anything right so
coming soon stay tuned right so so I
thought you know it's time to start
telling people about the project and I
need to start recruiting more and you
know I can't have potential candidates
looking at the website I'll scam company
right so so I said I'll update my
website and I you know I create a new
website and I you know told a few people
on this court about it's a new website
check it out and then I create a
telegram group and all these other
things and in my telegram group went
from zero to five thousand people in
four days
and then I had thousands of emails
asking me how they came making vestments
and begging me for allocations and and
she just say I'm not really sure like
where these people come from
but just judging from sort of you know
talking to I would say talking to you a
random sample of them because I really
don't know how to how to choose from
these people um and there are other
people who are interested from India
there's there's people from Brazil who
are interesting this there are obviously
a lot of Americans I think you know
there's a group of people in Turkey who
apparently are interestingness as well
very few people in China because all my
communication have been written in
English although there happen the attack
article is written about me in Chinese
which is very interesting
not really sure why but I think I think
maybe my mic maybe I think the attention
on getting a sort of Mirrors the
distribution of the Nano community right
because I told a lot of people about
sort of how I'm voting on top of nano
and I think there's a lot of excitement
from the Nano community that there is a
sort of a smart contract project that's
built on top of block lattice so now
those not a well-known project in new
China very very very few people have
heard of it so I guess it's only natural
that the people who are sort of paying
attention to my project don't currently
come from China now obviously I intend
to change that but you know exactly how
I'm gonna do that is still so so in
question so right now I would think that
it's probably everywhere except China
I'm not really sure what about an option
where do you think an option on tree
yeah yeah is that Geographic is that so
does that argue first items so being so
being very tactical right so I think
that um because if you're working with
IOT devices naturally you want to you
want to go to places in the world that
are sort of major manufacturing centers
of IOT devices right so so then you
start looking at places like China and
Japan I think those are very natural
places to develop this technology
because you know you want to be working
so the eventual goal it would be great
if we can actually start integrating a
lot of the protocol into devices
directly I couldn't have been in your
factory well right when when there were
new manufactured but of course this is
something that only works if you have
compounding applications and business
models on the back end or else the
device makers now why am I doing this
right why am i adding additional cost to
this so but in any case I think it's
it's um it's very interesting you have
to look at these market and China I
think this particular is going to be
pretty interesting market now you know
this once again this is being recorded
right so it's technically I guess I'm
not really sure this doesn't honest
answer I'm not really sure how it legal
it is because the government says is the
legal Chu in China right the Chinese
government says that I co surely go you
know you know that's definitely illegal
because that did no I understand that
because like 99% of ICL's are scams
people just take the money and run right
so okay that makes sense
cryptocurrencies are also illegal okay
so that's sort of connected I see oh but
we love blockchain so not really sure
where that sort of cognitive dissonance
is capital really depends on whether
your token is an asset for investment or
whether it's a functional item for doing
as far as I know the those sort of fine
grained distinction is not being made so
I don't I think I I spent a couple month
in the US I think I left I left Shanghai
in January and in stay in the US for two
month while you're talking to a lot of
people and trying to recruit the team
and my perception has always been what's
illegal in China
so if crypto currencies banned and
obviously bashing is bad so you can't
have any applications in blocking in
China so China has Denmark it no way
right and then I started talking to you
you know my extended team and I biased
or they're like no the console companies
doing blocking project and I'm like
isn't that illegal
and they're like look it's China right
so young don't know right their
governments you know they're I think
government inch engine is like
sponsoring bashing projects or coming
Hangzhou is sponsoring so is Italy I'm
not I don't know I honestly don't know I
mean there are there I mean the Central
Bank of China is researching their own
cryptocurrency so Howard legal is this
so I think
considered our bills ever been
considered an Internet of thing a thing
they could be blockchain supported in
any federal government I mean could
bills and coins that were administered
by a central bank be considered in like
a encouraging and I have t.i card leg
paper money or well I think I think you
would just replace it right you would
just replace it with a cryptocurrency
I think it's very likely that and and I
don't mean I I might not know what I'm
talking about it's very likely that the
Chinese government will release a
cryptocurrency that replaces the RMB and
that would be that would be
revolutionary I think you know in terms
of the in terms of the amount of sort of
I wouldn't say control but I guess the
amount of oversight they can exert on
the economy because then you have
there's no tax evasion there's no money
laundering there's really no anything
right because everyone is perfectly
visible so that would be that would be a
very interesting I think outcome right
you do you sort of watch for yeah you
wouldn't really need paper money at that
point very fascinating talk no the way I
understand you make money is you build
ecosystem and then you give up token to
whoever work for you or provide service
when the ecosystem is speaking now if
someone wants you users if you ecosystem
they have to get who you're talkin their
support for service exchange yeah no I
mean at the end if you wanted token to
be valuable you still have to change it
into US dollar or whatever right so
that's how he works
yeah so yeah I mean the more similarity
cause that probably was not covered by
the tape people who are not part of the
who haven't signed the broadcast release
form your questions will not be here so
to repeat what you're talking about the
idea is that
as you build the ecosystem then the
tokens that really constitute the
ecosystem become how you really that's
they become items of value and so the
question is you still have to convert it
to something well that's well that's
that depends on when you know piece on
how to start taking bitcoins right I
mean you know when they took Bitcoin at
one point I think someone spent a
thousand Bitcoin you buy a piece or
something but that guy is regretting it
remember seeing vending machines in
Japan that were accepting but yeah this
line right so so yeah I mean once again
this is just a matter of adoption right
I mean as izing all things I think
cryptocurrency has an adoption curve
right now it's sure at the beginning of
the curve it's very difficult to use I
I'm always afraid I'll lose all my money
at some point because I send it to the
wrong address or something or lose my
key and whatever variety of reasons so
it's very scary for sort of you know the
average user it was scary for everybody
not just average users right so there is
there is some some ways to go in terms
of adoption but at some point you know
if everyone's using crypto currencies
for everything then yeah then you
wouldn't need to convert into fiat
currency but what you would actually see
happen is that you actually instead a
fiat currency you would actually see
ecosystem currency right which is sort
of what's happening today is that I mean
people always say that corporations have
become a lot more influential than
nation-states so this is probably an
interesting extension you know you don't
necessarily have corporations but you
have global economic economic ecosystems
whose currencies become very influential
right in a way that they're applied so
okay go ahead
she still happened in Shanghai and what
did you do
other than the hackathons to learn more
about blockchain Oh
so I the hackathons and and meetings and
the meetup they still happen on there on
a frequent basis in China so once again
that's a sign that it's not entirely
illegal what did I do to learn about
blockchain I just read I just went
online and I just kept reading all sorts
of white papers and you know all sorts
academic papers and just just kept
reading and reading that's that's how
you learn about that's how you learn
about blockchain I guess in China or
anything like that is online stuff I
mean there should be hospice on
blockchain okay look next question yeah
I'm the big example educate brilliant
truth like that you talked about dreams
collecting data over fields so I'm
wondering is your business model in that
case really gonna be b2b and what's the
involvement of the actual farmer is the
farmer know that somebody is kind of
settled backing on the drone and taking
photos and looking at pest control and
then sending back data is the farmer get
that for free and it's like we're good
donation isn't compensated but everybody
else's in the ecosystem so the question
has to do with the smart phones or smart
devices that may be able to buy and sell
their data on their own right how does
the lawyer suit the device lawyers don't
like that right so that's actually a
very interesting question because the
farmers typically go on the drones
so the drones are usually owned by the
operators and the distributors that
actually operate them so you might say
that it might be unfair for the you know
the for example the the drone operator
to own that data but then again they're
the ones who made the investments right
you actually collect that data so I
think it could be very around
I could see your rights licensing
agreement where the farmer would get a
royalty percentage maybe I mean the
essence on who takes the rules as in all
things right if something's not read out
profit well nobody really cares what
you're doing there's something becomes
very profitable
I'm sure the farmers will start caring
and then then people work something out
and it's it's a market I think things
which is work work it out by themselves
that's sort of how we how we see it I'm
sorry I forgot your second question yeah
so this is actually very interesting
question because so if you think about
selling data right data data selling is
very is very questionable because it's
not questionable it's it's it's hard
right so you on the buyer side you're
always wondering it's a data I'm getting
real it's that real data right and the
seller is always thinking well is this
guy gonna buy my data and start pirating
it right so there are no sort of
absolute technological solutions to both
these problems I mean there's never
really been any technological solution
for these problems now on the data
authenticity side what you could do is
that you could have a set of devices
that are may say for example made by the
manufacturer right so if I'm Toyota what
I can do is that every year I can
publish the list and say you know I
don't know how many cars they make say
that they made a million cars this year
and say I made a million cars and these
are the public keys and serial numbers
of these 1 million cars and any data
that come from are signed by these keys
came from my car's right any neither
they did not come from these keys did
not come from my car right so so that's
a way for you to know where the data is
coming from right another way for you to
know where data coming from you know
other people say well you can create an
algorithm that analyzes data see if it's
real well look if you can create an
algorithm to figure out that is real if
someone can fake it so that your
algorithm can tell it's real right so
that's not really a viable way to do it
now even with even with devices that
have validated sort of signatures is
still not foolproof
someone can still fake it they can rip
out the signature chip and put it on a
laptop and generate fake data they can
do that right it's always doable so
that's something that requires legal
recourse right on piracy sigh there's
just just
no way technology can solve any new
problem once I've sold you the data you
have the data period I can't force you
to forget about the data right there's
nothing forced forgetfulness in
cryptography so so if you start selling
out data then there's not much I can do
about it so from a technological
perspective so for a good data market
you really exist there needs to be an
off chain legal recourse so this
actually creates a very interesting
question is that well in the future
unchanged smart contracts have
corresponding offering legal contracts
right now would be a very interesting
problem to you to sort of look at
because that's really the only way that
you can enforce these types of things
now right now the way to sort of circle
not circumvent but to cushion this
problem is that I would think that the
operator of the data market in the
beginning they are some commercial
entity for example car block is probably
some commercial entity and these are
commercial entities and they will
provide a legal guarantee that if
something goes wrong they are sort of
arbitrators of people who you know we're
happy with their purchases right so but
that only really works in the short term
when the parties who are participating
on the platform are small and no right
it really becomes successful which is
wide adoption then parties become
completely unknown so then that becomes
very very difficult to enforce so then
you go into the question well ok so now
you cannot have anonymity on the
blockchain anymore so every single
person will actually transact via smart
contract on data need to provide their
real legal entities you know and and
somehow store that in with different
chain or whatever right and only gets
triggered when there's the one there's a
dispute so your so one of the one of the
people I thought you said that you're
creating this entire new legal system
that marries the option legal system
unchanged
all right so not really sure that's the
right solution but I think going forward
this problem will become more more
poignant as these type of sort of eco
systems
gain wider and wider adoption it's
something that we don't necessarily have
to think about right now but it's coming
yeah it's coming it will be a problem
that has to be resolved
it's on pace on plan yeah so what kind
of team do you need to develop in order
to build this project out oh yeah is it
mostly technology developers you're
gonna have people on the business side
yeah definitely so I think so already
early on I think you know it's for the
entire space is driven mostly by just
take technologists right um they're
mostly driven by you know game you know
hackers will have an interesting
technology deterring their spare time
and sort of published it and you know
you know somehow became very big and
they decided hey this could be my
livelihood and you started doing it you
know that's going to become rare and
very going forward and not only that's
gonna become rare and rare the sure the
idea of you if you build it they will
come through a mentality it's not really
going to work because you're going to
have very short directed focused
business development especially for IOT
cuz IOT is just not the IOT IOT is very
very hard it's very hard to build you
know sort of successful business models
with IOT data um and so you do need very
very focused business development teams
so that's absolutely necessary
so typically what's very interesting is
that in the in typical botching teams
there's sort of tech team and there's a
huge marketing king right who actually
are in charge of community engagement
and sort of market value management
they're there to make sure that to
continuously generate interest and hype
about the project so their market cap
doesn't go down a lot of these things
you know if you look at from a
traditional securities perspective seems
like market manipulation it is on a
large extent that's that's why the
government probably don't like it right
so some super teams with people selling
snake oil yeah definitely so so you have
you have you have you know tech King
you're detecting you have the marketing
team and sort of the community
engagement team and then increasingly at
least you know for AXA there will
definitely be a significant business
development team you know we're going to
be recruiting once we scale up we're
going to be recruiting people from
specific industry verticals right
automotive agriculture without people
who have domain-specific knowledge about
a specific vertical and have
relationships and you know
able to speak and articulate division
Wow to potentially ecosystem partners
that we're going to be working with so
okay it's all that's one more question
will end up we've got some refreshments
outside want to make sure that we have a
chance to talk informally okay last
question is okay look into the crystal
ball uh-huh in a couple of years are we
going to start to see this start to take
off or what do you what do you think
we're going to see what should we watch
for what do you think will be a major
significant event that shows that
blockchain is finally starting to move
into IOT systems IOT systems
oh yeah hmm well if we do our jobs right
blockchain will not really be talked
about right I mean I think I really I
really keep talking about is that if the
entire watching space doesn't job right
blockchain will not be talked about just
like we don't talk about tcp/ip today
yeah you should not be talking about
blockchain if you're talking about
blocking that means the state of the art
today is insufficient to me you know
commercial applications so one sign of
success for any boxing project is that
in the future nobody talks about
watching anymore it would just become
this invisible layer unnatural way for
natural ways unless you're done
now what would make what would so it's
hard for me to see what kind of signal
that you would have about IOT but I
think I don't know I think maybe things
are people have people start to have
much more I guess people start to
experience the world in a much richer
people have a much richer experience so
the world may indeed be you start to say
buying and selling of data that has
hasn't happened before
right well that's not normal people
don't usually see that I guess but
normal people I think I think or not I'm
sorry if this sounds they rocketed but
just that you know know everybody right
so everyone would would actually maybe
start to see a richer world because the
whole point of IOT devices is that they
provide data insights that enable some
sort of automation
some sort of intelligence right and
there are lot of things that today that
are rather pre manual or could be much
better could be lost smarter that are
not so so I mean life which is become
easier and in people would perceive the
world being a lot richer I guess great
yeah okay they're dirt I mean I can't
tell you like a specific event that what
this going to happen if we do our jobs
right because we do our jobs right you
know it's you know nobody would know
that you did anything at all yes that
sounds good let's all enjoy talking more
informally outside in the meantime
please join me for thanking Steven
[Applause]